y at il un épisode de la mythologie
grecque qui se rapproche de ce que vit
le monde depuis un an
ça c'est la grosse question à mon sens
pour revenir avec reboucler avec ce que
c'est initialement sur l'assaut du
capitole mercredi dernier je pense qu'on
a dans nos démocraties occidentales
un vrai sujet sur l'information mais
aussi sur la désinformation et il se
trouve que dans la mythologie grecque
je veux offrir un épisode qui est tout à
fait fascinant qui est le moment où ça
fait dix ans que la guerre de troie dur
toutes les troupes grecques sont épuisés
ulysse comme des autres n'a qu'une envie
c'est de rentrer chez lui et en plus à
chier les morts donc vraiment il n'y a
plus aucune issue militaire à la faire
et c'est là qu'on voit le triomphe de la
désinformation qui permet de gagner la
guerre de troie
puisque ulysse va voir un des
combattants grecque qui est aussi rusé
intelligent voire fourbe que lui qui
s'appelle sinon et ils lui offrent des
sommes considérables pour pouvoir aller
du côté troyen et faire croire aux
troyens que non seulement les grecs sont
repartis chez eux
alors en fait ils sont partis avec leur
navire et sont cachés derrière une
petite île et bell télé boschi en face
de 2,3 et faire croire également qu' ils
ont laissé aux dieux un présent le
cheval de troie le fameux cheval de
troie et donc il avoir les troyens il
leur explique que
il ya eu 4 chasse le grand devin qui
sait que si jamais le cheval de troie
était introduit du côté troyen
et bien si le passé les murailles ce
cheval alors toute la flotte grecque a
péri en mer et ce serait la fin de tous
les grecs comme que les troyens
évidemment hésite se demande s'il ne
s'agit pas d'un piège mais c'est
l'émotion qui prend le dessus
c'est sinon qui réussit à désinformer
les trois y ans et c'est ça qui est
cause toutes leurs pertes puisque vous
avez la fin de l'histoire
à l'intérieur du cheval de troie que
finalement on amène à l'intérieur des
murailles mais il y avait dix soldats il
y avait eu 10 ils ouvrent ils égorgent
les sentinelles et ouvre les portes de
la ville et puis tout le monde paie vie
le vieux roi priam et c est donc
aujourd'hui en laissant le cheval de
troie de la désinformation rentrer dans
nos cités je trouve que ça fait penser à
la désinformation de la guerre de troie
et que l'on risque de menaces est
véritablement les fondements de la
démocratie
[Musique]